if you're still skeptical about the
intelligence community consensus that
Russia meddled in our election to help
Donald Trump consider that they now have
been caught meddling in the Trump Russia
investigation California Democrats
Dianne Feinstein and Adam Schiff senator
Feinstein and congressman Schiff
respectively release the letter the CEOs
of Twitter and Facebook warning of
possible Russian influence on the
special counsels investigation a website
monitoring Russian linked twitter
accounts found that their use of the
hashtag released the memo is up 300,000
percent now what is this release the
memo thing released the memo relates to
a house Intel committee decision to give
members of Congress a memo which
supposedly outlines abuses of FISA the
Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Act by
the FBI and there are some Republicans
who read the memo who said they were
shocked and even outraged about the
contents of the memo
even though the memo itself is itself is
still classified so they can't actually
tell us what specifically are they so
outraged outraged by right there saying
it's outrageous what's in the memo but
we can't tell you what so outrageous
because it's classified and it has
become a fantastic distractor from the
Trump Russia investigation and in fact
the David Pakman show has been impacted
by this as well all over our YouTube
channel there's these poorly written
troll comments which typically are these
foreign troll accounts that are looking
to spread this information talking about
how the real issue is not the Trump
Russia investigation
it's not Jeff Sessions being questioned
by robert muller it's released the memo
twitter exact same thing I'm getting
floods of tweets saying David the real
issue is and of our release the memo for
is to justice and IM trump right so like
terribly written stuff but what you can
pick out from all of them that's that's
an imaginary example is release the memo
if you look on reddit there are entire
sub reddits riddled with posts about
release the memo and what
there are not this memo is scandalous
isn't the issue
if the memo is scandalous then we should
find out about it evaluate and take
action is necessary but release the memo
has no bearing or impact on robert
molars path towards figuring out what
happened but that's how it's being used
videos and social media posts about the
Moller investigation and now at reaching
Jeff Sessions and wanting to interview
Trump they get flooded with comments
about release the memo and I say fine
release it but allow the investigation
to continue because there are two
separate issues
well it's interesting cuz one side says
that this is a red herring and you know
if there is something scandalous in that
memo it has no bearing on what the
Mueller team find that's my view the
other side is that if they did obtain
things unethically perhaps without a
warrant
then everything goes out the window
because if it's like a police officer
you know it doesn't have a warrant and
conducts a search on your house they
find drugs or something makes implicate
you for the crime cept if the Boston
Police Department did that and then you
say a Cambridge police investigation is
now a tainted you we would say well hold
on a second the fact that the Boston
Police is accused of doing something
doesn't mean a particular investigation
by Cambridge Police is now
invalid this is the Moller investigation
and there is no evidence whatsoever that
there has been anything untoward that
has taken place there despite the fact
that the right likes to paint him as
some kind of partisan hack and if he is
he's a lifelong Republican so I would
ask which party is he a hack for there's
also a difference between any potential
criminal prosecution and political
ramifications like say an impeachment
trial that wouldn't be affected either
no doubt about it so what's going on
here is that they want to create an
environment where the Americans that or
Americans in general if they could if
they could have it their way see the FBI
as the bad guys not the good guys and
they've been doing it for some time and
the Russian troll BOTS are jumping on
this release the memo thing Bigley in
order to try to continue distracting
from what is it's a very quickly
advancing investigation by robert muller
that now has reached trump's cabinet and
is pushing
it's way into the Oval Office the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad